nothing matters more than understanding
where the actual attention is versus
where the perceived attention is and the
perceived attention is usually garnered
by the icons and leaders of the world
sports team owners want to see
television commercials to feel like
their league is relevant while 90 of
Their audience is consuming it here that
is the only thing that matters if you're
trying to grow and it's the most
dangerous thing if you're declining
without realizing it what are you most
excited about in the world right now
business and personal in the world like
the one thing that jazzes you up the
most right this second let me talk very
little about my personal life but like
no question the majority of my children
is like by far like them becoming like
very real people is like
disproportionately the most interesting
thing but to keep it in context that I
think will bring value to people on this
interview and call like the the fact the
world's changing so much yeah you know
I'm best in chaos I'm a purebred
entrepreneur I have great consumer
intuition I'm comfortable and change and
I like when change is happening the fact
that the average Tick Tock star is more
famous than a prime time actor on an NBC
show right now
and
and people don't really like the
establishment doesn't realize that but
like I like you know the fact that like
not everybody
is aware of what brands are cool what
character what musicians are like like
knowing the pulse and then distribution
right like people's attention going to
YouTube shorts or
Ott or you know Tick Tock where things
like Instagram are now mature and not
emerging you know where you know that
stuff yeah just watching Tick Tock sort
of uh become how Netflix disrupted the
primary content industry and Netflix
poured so much money into content
and Tick Tock became more valuable than
Netflix almost overnight in a business
sense by not paying for Content but
giving a microphone to the world and
allowing creators to to be there yeah I
think you know
curation and platform are two great ways
and I think Tick Tock and Netflix are
the Contemporary winners of what you
know call it
HBO and Facebook of 2012 was winning
right HBO would curate content and they
were the big winner and Facebook gave
the world pages and fan pages or Twitter
and here we are 10 years later and to
your point that same game of being on
either side of the coin either be the
platform that allows people to fill the
pipes or be a distribution platform that
fills the pipes by spending money and
being good at it are two very
interesting different games and I think
they'll always be winners
in both sides of that equation yeah I
mean sticking with with the platforms
you know you you once said that you
built your career on attention Arbitrage
right essentially investing in attention
on up and coming platforms when
attention is cheap there and then
switching to the newer platforms when
the price per reach or engagement on
those platforms increase so uh what what
did you mean by that and how do you and
and the Vayner brand approach the
attention economy and attention
Arbitrage
it's the only thing that I think about
really really I'll tell you why
understanding what you just broke down
that I've spoken about in Clarity at
times is that quote or in innuendo as I
do on a daily basis
there really is nothing else it's the
reason John F Kennedy beat Richard Nixon
in the election because television was a
different medium than radio it's the
reason
Obama and Trump both won their elections
it's the reason uh Michael Jackson and
Madonna were the biggest pop stars in
the world because they understood the
value of MTV
when Elton John and the Rolling Stones
didn't
um and I can give you 74 billion other
examples and I just gave you a couple
off the top of my head in four seconds
nothing matters more than understanding
where the actual attention is versus
where the perceived attention is
and the perceived attention is usually
garnered by the icons and leaders of the
world the establishment
where they want to see it right
um
Sports I'll give you a great one sports
team owners
want to see television commercials to
feel like their league is relevant right
now yeah he was relevant to them when
they were kids
the 65 to 80 year old
58 to 80 year old current Sports owner
from the English Premier League to the
NHL NFL NBA MLB and everything in
between want to see Billboards and
television spots to feel as if they're
communicating their sport
while
90 of Their audience is consuming it
here yeah
that is perceived attention is on
billboards and television versus actual
attention is on Tick Tock and Twitter
and Spotify and Netflix right yep that
is the only thing that matters if you're
trying to grow and it's the most
dangerous thing
if you're declining without realizing it
if you're the incumbent where's the next
where's the next attention Arbitrage
opportunity no idea I for yeah I'll tell
you why what about the friends
yeah three yeah I think I think web3 I
think metaverse in an Oculus or
something like it is clearly an
opportunity the reason I say I have no
idea is even though I'm very aware of
what AR and VR could do to the attention
economy
speaking to it from a timing standpoint
is not appropriate right now because it
leaves me in a very vulnerable spot of
being wrong
whereas what I like doing is nobody was
louder about tick tock four years ago
than me literally nobody
as a human being saying this is what you
should do it is incredibly well
documented that 48 months ago 36 months
ago that that I was the loudest
and that feels great because I was right
not because I understood that Tick Tock
was coming it was that it already had
been there well I'll give you an out
please you have clearly said 95 of
projects in the nft space are going to
zero but you're also bullish on this
space so what's the well well that has
nothing to do with attention
and it no I agree nfts has nothing to do
with attention which is why I kind of
took the conversation where I took it if
we want to Veer which I love doing I'm
I'm I'm coming right in with you that
they are there is the technology the
consumer blockchain and what an nft
actually allows something to happen
allows for things to happen that the
internet and the analog world do not
allow which is a contract
in perpetuity
that is
non-manipulable and universally accepted
is a profound technology shift at scale
yeah so so what is an nft uh behind me
right including be friends I don't know
if people are listening or watching but
I have a lot of Collectibles right I
have um sports cards and comic books and
all sorts of collectible toys
Disney today on eBay today on eBay
Disney will probably transact I um by
the way for everyone's listening I'm
going to make this number up because I
have no clue but my intuition is
millions of dollars
of Disney Collectibles will sell on eBay
today
so now today
uh Millions
let me tell you who will make money in
that transaction
the person that bought that Mickey Mouse
toy at a garage sale for five bucks and
sold it for 30.
eBay with all their service fees as
being a middleware
FedEx
UPS
right all will take money
you know who will not make a penny on it
Disney
think about that
now project 30 years from now where
Disney the friends Corporation
and every other intellectual property
and artist Andy warhol's painting is
going to sell tomorrow at Christie's
who's gonna make money Christies
the current owner of the Andy Warhol
piece right the armed truck that is
going to ship it to Morocco
right
who's not the Andy Warhol family
the consumer
blockchain and nfts dust because of it
if it just enables The Originals of Art
and intellectual property to keep
significant percentages in perpetuity of
the intellectual property and the demand
creation that they are able to create is
a profound shift in Commerce of the
magnitude that is almost impossible to
comprehend however that is only one
slipper
of what a consumer blockchain can do
for example
going to I'm going to the Jets game on
Monday night
I'm gonna get into that Stadium using a
QR code
that is currently today
a more
advanced technology than what I did when
I was a teenager which is I would take a
piece of paper and give them a ticket in
between they put a barcode on that
ticket that they would scan so they
couldn't counterfeit
literally as a child people would make
counterfeit tickets to sporting events
literally that doesn't exist anymore
because of barcodes now it doesn't exist
anymore because of QR codes I believe
easily within the next decade
um we will see ticketing go to QR codes
excuse me to nfts here's why going back
to eBay if everybody who's listening
right now goes to eBay and searches
collectible tickets ticket stop Ticket
Stop enter you see where I'm going right
brother absolutely that's how you sell
tickets to your conference right that's
right that well I wanted to create
that's the other thing back to the smart
contract I wanted to have more valuable
I wanted to have something valuable for
people while I was building the
intellectual property if if I'm
successful in building Transformers
Pokemon Disney
all the owners of these nfts will play
out to be winners because if you bought
a hundred copies of Superman
Action Comics number one in the 30s
because you thought Superman was going
to be big over the next 50 years you
would be a good trillionaire
so but in the short term I knew that
there'd be ups and downs we're living in
a down right now there's a bear Market I
thank you for saying it because I want
make sure nobody forgets I said 95 98 99
depending on the mood I was in on an
interview but it was always minimally 95
or go in a zero
but the two to three percent were going
to be the you know the Pokemon the
Transformers the
Tom and Jerry's and snoopies and Hannah
barberas and so that's what I'm on but
in the short term I need time nobody
cares right now about intuitive iguana
right or major moth I have comic books
toys movies trading cards I got a lot of
work to do so I said I've got to bring
more value than just the collectible or
the long-term utilities because when I
have an amusement park in 15 years like
Six Flags or Busch Gardens or God
willing Disney World well the original
nft holders could have lifetime passes
for free that's pretty cool right I have
building to do in the short term I've
known that everyone's wanted for me
because I read my emails a super
business conference my Davos my my South
by Southwest my Coachella and that is
what vcon was and so when I sold the
original v-friends series Once it came
with a three-year ticket to vcon and we
had a very very successful vcon 1 which
I think sets us up extremely well for
vcon 2 and we'll get going
yeah that's great and Andreessen
Horowitz you may have just answered this
but Andreessen Horowitz just invested 50
million in the seed round for V friends
what can we expect for what's to come
with that project like what's your
vision there is it the building out the
value on all those characters
animation's expensive theme parks are
expensive uh and very much I'm a
businessman and I you know when we
negotiated that I was incredibly
concerned about the global economy
I have a very expensive staff building
out this work
um
I mean vcon was an eight-figure
execution cost a lot of money to rent
out an NFL student stadium for four days
build a three million dollar stage like
it costs money and so I wanted to have a
rainy day fund
uh and I'm happy we're doing that and
and honestly it's also smart money you
know Chris Dixon Chris Lyons Mark
Andreessen Brad Hart these are prolific
businessmen and women that you know have
already helped me in legal conversations
in tokenomics for the future in
relationship making and so I'm
incredibly excited about um about that
relationship yeah do you think uh so
like the decentralization piece of web 3
you know do you think Chris Dixon is
right and touting the potential for
decentralization or do you think Jack
Dorsey is right and that it's going to
be just concentrated like web 2.
I think they're both right
you think it's gonna be a little of both
yeah I think Chris is right because now
the technology exists and it didn't
before thus
people that are more creative more uh
ideological have options now you know I
wish Earth had an entire land mass
that was equal to the land mass of the
Earth where people who don't like any
governments could go and live and be
happy and play out their experiment
hmm that's what I think is happening
between Jack and Chris Dixon's debate
here people who want to be purely
decentralized Bitcoin
it's living
but let there be no confusion Jack's
absolutely right like
web 3 as most people call it is
predominantly web 2.5
you know open C is not decentralized
right right I mean look at even me V
friends you've got a whole world board
ape where they give ownership to the
holder you've got Kevin rose with moon
Birds giving creative comments everybody
can have ownership
and those are both two very powerful
ideas and then you've got me who's so
obsessed with doing Walt Disney you know
with doing character creation Hannah
Barbera I want to be Jim Henson and I
can't give you or Dustin commercial
rights because you might [ __ ] up the
Innovative Impala from the vision that I
have
I don't think board ape is wrong or
right with their ownership to the holder
I don't think Kevin Rose is right or
wrong with creative comments and I don't
think Gary vaynerchuk is wrong with
being fully in control of the IP I think
all three can flourish five percent of
the time and I think all three will fail
95 of the time
so I mean the consumer blockchain
obviously powering all of this there's a
lot of hurdles right now obviously
transaction costs are high transaction
volumes are low compared to say like a
Visa what are the key innovations that
are required to create Mass viability
the biggest the off chain is it like
lightning type stuff or the biggest
Innovation is a four-letter word called
time
more than the Brilliance of the young
men and women and old men and women that
come up with less frictionless less
friction and getting normal people to
understand and layering web 2 Dynamics
on the back of web 3 where you can pay
with Fiat and convert to you know crypto
and all the things that are so clearly
going to happen and are happening if you
are halfway thoughtful and are spending
time paying attention and not just
reading headlines all of this is
happening I listen you know this back to
Andreessen Horowitz laughs
nobody knew how to get on the internet
in the 90s until Mark Andreessen made
Netscape Navigator
like the browser did not exist there was
the internet and the browser the thing
that there's nobody in my office see a
bunch of running around 25 years old
that think about Google Chrome as
anything other than oxygen
that was a profound Innovation 30 years
ago that allowed normal people like me
who who were
normal people not Tech savants to get on
the internet today remembering your seed
phrase understanding what a custodial is
authorizing by clicking a contract that
steals your [ __ ] instead of this is all
the Wild Wild West that always happens
when profound you know I love when
people are like this [ __ ] is all I was
like this is exactly the tell that it's
big remember when your parents wouldn't
put their credit card into the internet
just gonna say that I was just that's I
remember that was the tell that's when I
knew it was going to be big yeah that
that people were scared to put their
credit card in yet many others did you
know for me
um I like this moment right now I think
we're in this place where a lot of the
get rich quick scheme Hustlers are
leaving because they can't make as much
money
it's become you know it's another I
really like this I think the thoughtful
Builders are now like I am putting in
more effort not less during this bear
market and so it's a fun time and but I
think the biggest Innovation my friend
is just time like there's nothing that
was going to be more powerful in 2000
when the entire Internet stock market
crashed yeah when everyone was like
what's gonna for the people that believe
the way I did then
what do we need to do to make sure this
gets people to buy on the internet the
answer was time yeah it's generational
there's it's like every single 14 year
old in the world
has been built as a human being on the
back of Minecraft Roblox NBA 2K gaming
Candy Crush virtual good like they don't
even know any different
yeah no you're right and some of them
don't know the history of back in the
day either so I I speak to a lot of
young Executives and you know I try to
throw back to oh man you know like that
reminds me of snow crash you know and
they're like oh what's that I've never
read that I don't even know what you're
talking about oh I was talking to Tim
berners-lee the other day who's that I
have no idea who that is you know
history so history you know you're gonna
like this I don't know where it is let
me see if I can find it report card
report card you see it Dustin anywhere
oh actually I'm sorry I've made it front
and center this is a really good time to
say this so this is my report card I was
an atrocious student but if you look at
it amongst all the D's and F's these are
literally just so you can see it actual
D's and F's I don't know if you see
something very much stands out sophomore
year might only be
was in Northwestern worlds Western world
history junior year all these but I got
a B in drawing
be friends
even though I know a lot of people make
fun of me for it but I also got a B in
Cold War history and world wars right
and it goes on same thing happened
senior year like and same thing happened
freshman year history will always tell
you the future
from that but I also think that the
future invented without the burden of
history is also different than the
future invented with the incumbents view
of what happened so they can think of
things that that's pretty burdened by
the the I love you for saying that I was
saying I'm obsessed with which is fresh
eyes or dangerous eyes right one my lack
of I actually am very passionate about
history from a macro human psychology
but one of the reasons I've been able to
be a very successful entrepreneur and
I'm comfortable saying that is actually
grounded in lack of knowledge let me
give you an example in the meta I'm
sitting in my office right now at Vayner
we're 13 years in
I've really been running it for 11.
first two years was really more my
brother I was still doing the liquor
store thing
we are undoubtedly one of the one or two
largest independent advertising agencies
in the world
there's just no debate size of Revenue
size of people global
when I tell you I knew nothing
that would be the word I use nothing
about the history or the actual current
state of the advertising industry when I
started this company that is the truth I
didn't know how the divisions worked I
didn't know what all I knew was what we
started this conversation with which was
if Pepsi and the NHL and Campbell's and
GE are early clients did not get Twitter
and Facebook accounts they were going to
leave opportunity on the table
and that's to your point as long as all
the kids that we're trying to inspire
when I say kids I mean creative kid
thinking the 52 year old looking to
transition into their new job that to me
is a kid a creative like new set if we
can Inspire them to solve problems that
they clearly see
and not overvalue of how everybody tried
to solve it they will create some of the
most important Innovations of all time
yeah I can't wait I'm super excited like
you are about everything that's going on
this is the most I'll tell you this is
the most fun because when I was betting
on the internet and when I was betting
on social media nobody knew who [ __ ] I
was this one's a lot of fun for me
because this is now a year ago I'm a
hero I'm a genius
now
for a lot of people watching where the
nft market is they're laughing or
snickering or saying jokes behind the
back
that's my favorite this is the
underestimated moment right there is
only one foregone conclusion to what
happens with nfts they will be a
significant part of all of our Lives
yeah they're just not going to look the
way you know when I thought the internet
was going to be a significant part of
our lives in 1995
it was very much based around
information
yeah I would never have to go to the
library again
there was a lot more
but it was enough for me to get curious
and then I realized which is why I
launched an e-commerce site in 1996 that
it was going to change the way people
bought things
the way information the way
communication and the way that people
bought things was going to be changed
Forever by the internet
what the internet did for communication
the blockchain is about to do for
transactions yeah I think that's a very
good way to put it actually what about
so one thing I've been thinking a lot
about recently is thinking a little bit
more in depth about scarcity because
essentially you know uh you've got this
situation where
um
you know it's a huge factor for nfts
because digital goods are infinitely
copyable
in the same Fidelity in High Fidelity
and infinite number of times like the
cost of reproducing a digital good is
zero but the value of an nft is that
it's a validated ownership of something
that is potentially unique or low in
number right but there's a lot more
important strategy I think to be
invented around scarcity so I've been
talking say to uh
um to artifact which was purchased by
Nike and the whole concept even in board
ape and so on of having you know various
characteristics of characters and having
them some of them be super rare some of
them be rare some of them and then now
scarcity isn't binary it's not like
scarce or not scarce or abundant it's
nuanced this product has n Dimensions
some of them are scarce some of them are
kind of rare some of them are very
common you know and so the digital
strategy of conceptualizing scarcity and
maintaining sort of luxury good pricing
and branding where but at the same time
scaling which is now possible because
these original Goods on the cost side
well I think a lot about it it's
actually think supply and demand is the
one natural gift I have so let me take
an interesting Counterpoint uh not a
Counterpoint actually let me add a
additive point that I think people
aren't paying attention to
I believe and I was very thoughtful I
loved what you just said by the way so
kudos to your thinking I believe smart
people like you
are spending way too much time on Supply
and that the punch line to everything is
demand
so let's talk it out I think if you look
at be friends I think the thing that
people don't pay attention to is series
two has 55
000
555 units
and has maintained stronger during this
period of time than a lot of the
projects that have 10 000 because that
was became the magic number because a
crypto Punk's history but you uh Dustin
who's filming right now great guy on my
team creative guy like I have a lot of
fondness for him uh if he made an nft
today
and made six of them
very scarce
I do not believe the price of those
things would be more valuable than my
hundreds of thousands between Book Games
be friends one be friends two mini drops
I believe that a lot of people have
spent so much time on manufacturing
thoughtful strategy around scarcity and
supply
but that most people do that because
they are incapable of creating demand
well I mean you just brought it right
back to the attention economy where we
started right that's right so and then
and then it becomes the story economy
right like Hansel and Gretel Tom and
Jerry
right Fred Flintstone those things
accomplished
the ability I I don't want to get too
political here but
religion
yeah lore
Zeus like a Zeus reel but everyone knows
what Zeus is like and then how about
just historical figures do we like I
don't know I grew up my whole life
thinking Christopher Columbus was the
greatest in my childhood and the
narrative changed
story it is to your point yes there's
the marketing part of actually knowing
how to Market to create demand which I
would argue 99 of Brands and I put nft
projects in there struggle heavily in a
2023 environment be
a completely separate thing is even if
you got the whole world to watch your
Super Bowl commercial
are you good enough to tell a story in
30 seconds to get people to give a [ __ ]
about the humbled Hedgehog right am I
going to be good enough like when I sit
with you and talk and I look at the
humble Hedgehog and the caring camel my
ability to make video games my ability
to do children's books
my ability to do trading cards
all of that is going to be the ultimate
variable of The Upside against my
ability to be as great as anybody on the
attention economy from a marketing
standpoint the attention the fact that I
built vaynermedia for myself which is
now manifesting with be friends and I'm
who I've been for the last 30 years puts
me in a no lose situation with be
friends because I'm always going to be
able to create enough demand just on
that skill if I'm right that I also have
Dr Seuss Jim Henson Vince McMahon Walt
Disney
uh the the people behind the woman the
amazing woman behind Barney like if I
have that skill too
on top of
well then over the next 25 years
something crazy is going to happen
that's that's a really interesting and
great way to look at it I think I
completely agree with you I think that
attention maybe is undervalued when
Supply is overvalued in terms of
strategic thinking these days that's uh
it's because people can manipulate and
strategize and put pen to paper to
control Supply yeah but to create demand
is the most merit-based truth on Earth
yeah that's uh that's that's and it's
not just marketing it's not taking the
product that you have and marketing it
do you know what I do you know what I
say a lot to a lot of our clients in a
pitch if I don't believe in the product
after I hear what they're about I go you
don't want to hire us we're so good at
marketing we're going to speed up the
world realizing your product sucks
it's I can get everybody over the next
10 years on The Tick Tock or Instagram
or Facebook or or Netflix commercials of
the day to know everything about V
friends if I'm not good at making the V
friends thing interesting after you've
become aware of it I'm gonna lose yeah
it's Why Super Bowl commercials fail
everyone sees them but if it's not good
you lose it's why TV shows that get a
prime slot right whatever show NBC in
the 90s wanted to be a hit that they put
after friends because the lead-in was so
remarkable the reason that show didn't
win is because the show didn't win but
the [ __ ] opportunity was there yeah
so what if you let's say you were Zuck
how would you change Facebook well let's
say you were Adam Masari how would you
change Instagram let's say you were Jack
Dorsey or para Gaga or Elon how would
you change Twitter pick any of those or
all of them and give give the platform
leaders some direct advice I think every
one of those platforms I put snap in
there as well need to take a very
specific nuanced
thing out of tick tock only one
Tick Tock and it's starting to change
because supply and demand of attention
tick tock
did not cap
your upside
of the creative
regardless of how many followers and how
much work you put in it could have been
your first day three years ago and you
could have made a really good coffee
video for tick tock and you could have
got 93 million views and that could have
changed your trajectory the cap
of upside of the variable of the quality
of your creative that the other
platforms have in stream
is there great vulnerability and their
great opportunity if tomorrow my
Instagram videos did not play in the
same general range of 400 000 to 1.5
million per view and it looked more like
8 000 views and 8 million views
everything would change for Adam yeah
that's such a great suggestion and you
see it Instagram's starting to go in
that direction they're realizing this
there's a fundamental design difference
between Tick Tock and the rest of them
where your networks of followers and so
on it's not a digital social network
it's a it's a series of channels that
anybody can watch anything and I think
it's you know I think publicly I saw
this you know I don't pay enough
attention this because I just stay in
the dirt and create and learn from the
real thing but I did hear from my
platform team here at Vayner in a report
I caught it which I always skim so I was
pumped I caught this that Facebook meta
excuse me meta I think has come out and
actively said that going forward
virality AKA outside your network that
you follow content was going to go from
and I might be making this up but my
brain says from 15 to 35 percent of your
feed so that means they're already going
in that place I think the Holy Grail is
pure Merit I think the next and I don't
think Tick Tock is fully there I think
the next version that disrupts Tick Tock
literally looks like
seven views and nine million in back to
back posts by the same person and brand
if you can get to a hundred percent
Merit based on whatever algorithm
Quantum qual metrics you use and every
other thing how long they say on the
post every whatever your algo is whoever
Masters that
is going to really intoxicate the world
of Brands and influencers and creators
key there because
because really going to be liked and
engaged with what the album what what
the AI and the Algos are going to be
able to do though is even if the algo
makes the assumption that it's going to
be good it still has the next human that
consumes it to make it smarter
I I can tell you for sure that I've seen
content in my life when I've stumbled
into like paying attention to it of my
own that starts off ripping hot and
calms down
versus starts off ripping hot and gets
crazy yeah and when I look at it
subjectively when I think about the 10
15 comp piece of content I'm thinking
about right now
it makes sense to me like the one that
went universally does make more sense to
me that it was working versus listen to
what I said it's very careful versus the
other half that didn't go there I think
really worked for my audience that was
already built in but was less Universal
you see where I'm going that my
assumption is properly the algo this is
mainly meta Instagram
understood like oh this is working for
my people thus it's working oh wait a
minute as it's going broader people that
don't know Gary don't give a [ __ ] as
much
and so I I think that game is going to
really matter it's just everything keeps
going further towards Merit SoundCloud
and Spotify is more Merit than paying
off radio stations and MTB to play your
[ __ ] can we unpack Merit for a second
because you've also said that negativity
is louder than positivity yes you
basically hate out muscles love online
we've kind of found the same thing in a
10-year study of Twitter we found that
false news spreads farther faster deeper
than the truth right and so when we
think about Merit yes people are being
are engaging with a lot of toxic content
obviously online right and and so how do
we change that right is it just getting
happy truthful humans to be louder uh is
that the simple answer or what do we do
the complicated answer is we need a
remarketing of Parenthood
so the world's currency
of humanity is predicated on using fear
as a weapon and that starts at home
the reason we're conducive to it to
politicians is because our parents
deployed it from the beginning
then speak into a dad so I'm hearing you
brother this [ __ ] has got me going like
you can't imagine I
am the byproduct of a mother
who [ __ ] it's so emotional for me
it's like tough to even talk about
publicly I I'm literally writing a book
called perfectly parented
of course I mean I could see here for
six hours and tell you what my parents
did wrong
but they so did right on accountability
and
and loving and cheering for the right
things my my mother didn't she punished
me for bad grades but there was never a
day where I thought my self-worth was
tied into my schoolwork
my self-worth was tied into the things
she cheered about and made important
which was how I treated other human
beings
when I mean these are real stories of my
life when somebody would fall and trip
and be hurt when we were playing in the
80s nobody thought about any of these
feelings and ideas and I would stop
playing and I would run over and care
about the kid that's the story my mom
would talk about over dinner
right when when I would stand up for the
kid that was getting picked on that's
what my mom not my parents overvalue
grades which teaches kids to believe in
systems that grade you subjectively
every hundred days
parents overvalue other parents opinion
of their kids which teaches kids to
Value other people's opinions
parents use fear to stop kids from doing
things that they're scared of
I'm scared shitless of dogs and water
this is real I Gary at 46 deep down I'm
not super comfortable around dogs and I
fear the water why because my mom did
and it's one of the few things I fear
around because it's one of the few
things that my mom and still fear around
if you fear getting a b you will work
for a company your whole life
we need a [ __ ] you know what this is
not face I love when everyone's like
zucks sucks my [ __ ]
people want to blame the algorithm
social media politicians governments we
have no level of accountability
parents [ __ ] on technology all day long
and then the second that they're having
a good time drinking wine they give the
iPad to the kid because they don't want
to be bothered no
parents hypocrisy at scale
parents being way too involved in their
kids thus over protecting them thus
telling children that they don't trust
them to be able to handle their own [ __ ]
has led to
the moment we are in and until we accept
that truth
until the older Millennials gen xers or
Boomers that [ __ ] on gen Z when they're
the ones who parented them
until they become accountable for their
shortcomings and until we teach gen zirs
don't do what we did
play it different we'll just have a
Perpetual machine of insecurity yeah
when you when you give advice to young
people you often encourage them to go
for uh their passions to start
businesses to start you know flipping
trading you know to to Tinker and try
things out so take two entrepreneurs
with equal love and passion for what
they do equal commitment to the Grind
equal access to resources relationships
money and equally good ideas
so what will make one more successful
than the other other than those four
things by the way by the way I just need
to say this because I'm hot I'm more
into Rose giving giving roses while
people are alive I'm enjoying the living
[ __ ] out of the thoughtfulness of this
interview I love it this question is a
profoundly great question ready for the
answer yeah
totally ready reps
I love it reps yeah you could talk about
exercising all day long right reps the
reason I'm unstoppable is because I
punted school and did entrepreneurship
from [ __ ] six
22 which is why I walked into my dad's
liquor store as a child 22 took full
reins of operations and in 25 seconds
changed everything
you know why because I was a [ __ ]
All-Pro Hall of Fame All-Star seasoned
[ __ ] veteran at 22 because I S and
don't forget what I did this is why I
like a lot of people getting jobs at
retail
in their youth
when you get that much human interaction
you get to learn I did lemonade stands
and baseball card shows my whole life I
rang doorbells to wash cars and shovel
snow I got 7 trillion no's and a couple
thousand yeses which did two things it
taught me how to get a yes and more
importantly it taught me how to be
comfortable with a no
I love it I love it you know my son
started his first lemonade stand this
summer uh lefties lemons because he's a
lot he's alive I love it branded it yeah
lefties lemons we're gonna make merch so
get ready I wanna I want a t-shirt I
will I'm telling you right now you email
me I'm a medium t-shirt make it soft
because I don't like the hard [ __ ] yeah
and I will [ __ ] rock that t-shirt
okay
oh you're it's coming it's coming last
question yes last question
so when you think of all the people
you've known in business and the people
you've come across who always seem to be
one step ahead of the Innovation curve
the ones that you can pick out that you
know who are just like yep and that
person is always one step ahead
what traits stand out to you as common
among those people some sort of
concoction if I made like a if I blended
it and made like a smoothie uh and I'm
thinking about people like Kevin Rose
Scott belski you know uh Mike Lazaro
Aaron Battalion I went to I went to
school with Mike I love it so those
individuals that popped in my head right
away Brit Morin uh is they have a mix
here's here's the here's the shake uh
tons of yes DNA that's probably like the
banana that's like the core yes DNA the
answer to anything is hey what about
nfts yes what about virtual reality yes
what about going to Mars yes it's yes
comma let me dig
in a world where almost everyone's know
that is a similar thing and it's maybe
the same exact thing but I'll say it a
little bit differently so a bunch of yes
a bunch of curiosity they even get into
those conversations by being curious
right I was at a dinner the other day I
know nothing about mining like mining
for materials like nickel and diamonds
and I listened for two hours I'm a
talker and listen for two hours pepper
this guy with a ton of questions my
basis of like thinking about buying land
around the world now for mining is like
now gone from zero to it's in my purview
and maybe in seven years I'll get deeper
and maybe something will happen right
be friends is the byproduct of buying
pop culture items at garage sales my
whole life
that was the smoke the friends was the
fire so yes
curiosity
being an athlete versus being
a person in attendance watching an
athlete that would be the third
characteristic what does that mean
you're comfortable with people booing
you on your home field constantly I'm a
Nixon Jets fan
I'd go to a lot of games
those players get booed at home a lot
the ability to have the skin to be booed
I am booed every single day on Twitter
and and Instagram and tick tock that is
being drowned out by a lot of cheering
because I'm doing well and I'm a good
guy but there's still tons of booing
which cripples people
and it cripples them in making content
and it definitely cripples them in being
an entrepreneur because when your
company fails or when you're wrong about
the next big thing everybody makes fun
of you and if you can't deal with the
nose and the booze then you're finished
so it is a thick skin to being willing
to be wrong it's being a baseball player
you're willing to go three out of ten
because you know that gets you in the
hall of fame most people want to just
sit and watch you play baseball and
judge you for being three of ten
I love it I really really appreciate
this conversation Gary thank you for
saying that earlier I feel the same way
thank you brother I learned a ton I
can't wait to to talk to you again and
thanks for all the time we really really
appreciate it love you pal take care
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]